[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
nach israelischen Angaben hat die Hamas
199 Geiseln in den Gazastreifen
verschleppt hinter diesem Terror steckt
auch das zynische Kalkül Israels Armee
vor ein schier unauflösliches Dilemma zu
stellen es ist gewissermaßen eine neue
Dimension der altbekannten Taktik
Zivilisten als Schutzschilder zu
benutzen und Teil eines Krieges bei dem
sich nur eine Seite Gedanken über zivile
Opfer und Völkerrecht macht das dürfte
auch ein Grund sein warum Israel die
angekündigte Bodenoffensive bislang
nicht gestartet hat lückwalpot berichtet
Hilfe für Gaza wäre da direkt an der
Grenze zu Ägypten stehen Medikamente
Lebensmittel Ausrüstung bereit ein paar
hundert Meter weiter sind auch diese
Menschen bereit aus dem belagerten
Gazastreifen auszureisen Palästinenser
mit ausländischem Pass wie diese Familie
aus Duisburg beim Verwandten Besuch
zwischen die Kriegsfronten
geraten diese Nacht war sehr sehr
kritisch auch da gab's vi es W viel
bombardiert und man konnte nicht richtig
schlafen also wir hatten die ganze Zeit
Angst dass
dass unser Haus sozusagen bombardiert
wird ja wir haben mit der deutschen
Botschaft geredet und die haben gesagt
dass wir rauskommen doch die Türen sind
trotzdem zugeblieben und jetzt hoffen
wir dass wir heute rauskommen vergeblich
die Grenze bleibt geschlossen israel
will palästinensische Zivilisten nach
Ägypten ziehen lassen aber keine
Hilfsmittel nach Gaza reinlassen das
könnte Hamas nützen
will Hilfe für die Zivilisten
reinbringen aber keine unkontrollierte
Masseneinwanderung aus Gaza und es recht
keine Hamas Kairo das machte
Außenminister schukri seiner
französischen Kollegin kolona heute
deutlich hat selbst genug leidvolle
Erfahrungen mit islamistischem Terror
Ausländer will man in Rafa passieren
lassen aber nur wenn Israel Hilfe
passieren
lässt bislang gab es leider aus Israel
keinerlei Signale dass sie eine Öffnung
der Grenze akzeptieren
würden im Gegenteil Israels
Armeesprecher wurde deutlich es gab
Nachrichten wonach wir humanitäre Hilfe
nach Gaza hinein lassen das ist nicht
der Fall die Grenze ist geschlossen es
gibt keine
Feuerpause wohl als klare Warnung
landete am Nachmittag eine israelische
Rakete unmittelbar neben dem
Grenzübergang bereits letzte Nacht hatte
die Armee ihre Luftangriffe auf Gaza
noch einmal ausgeweitet für die Bewohner
gibt es kaum Schutz mehr als 2700 tote
melden die palästinensischen Behörden
bisl in Israel liegen unterdessen noch
mehr als 500 Leichen in Kühlhäusern
Opfer der Hamas terrorüberfälle die so
entstellt sind dass sie noch nicht
identifiziert werden konnten wegen
raketenalarms mussten die Knesset
Abgeordneten heute aus dem Plenum in den
Schutzraum Israel richtet sich Krieg ein
und der Regierungschef warnt Iran sich
nicht
einzumischen den Fehler habt ihr schon
einmal gemacht aber diesmal wird der
Preis für euch sehr viel
höher viel zu tun für US Außenminister
blinken nach seiner nosttour zurück in
telaviv es gilt eine brandgefährliche
Kettenreaktion zu
verhernresondich Sitzung Gasastreifen in
der Nähe von Aschkelon Michael gibt es
jetzt zur Stunde noch neue Informationen
zu einer möglichen Grenzöffnung zu
Ägypten
hin also es sieht weiterhin nicht nach
einer Grenzöffnung aus und die
israelische harte Haltung verdeutlicht
vielleicht in Ereignis ein Bombenangriff
bei dem es kaum Schäden gab unser
Mitarbeiter vor Ort im Süden von Gaza
berichtet von einem solchen wo es gar
keine verletzten keine Toten gegeben hat
wo nur palästinensische Grenzanlagen auf
Gaza Seite offenbar beschädigt worden
sind und das ist das klare Signal der
Israelis an Ägypten wagt es nicht
irgendwelche Hilfslieferungen ohne
unsere Zustimmung nach Gaza zu schicken
denn sonst werden die angegriffen die
israelische Haltung bleibt hart man will
keinen humanitären Korridor erstmal
zulassen obwohl die Lage dort unten auch
weiterhin dramatisch ist unser Kollege
berichtet von Menschen die auf dem
nackten Boden auf der Straße schlafen
weil es schlicht keine Unterkünfte gibt
dass die Nahrungsmittel zu Ende gehen
und auch Wasser immer schwieriger zu
bekommen ist aber Israel sagt viele
Mitglieder der Regierung sagen das wenn
es einen humanitären Korridor geben soll
dann nur gegen die Freilassung von
Geiseln und kommt Bundeskanzler Scholz
morgen nach Israel und reistß dann auch
weiter nach Ägypten das ist ja auch Teil
einer internationalen e die man jetzt
beobachten kann was was sollte oder
könnte da erreicht
werden also ich denke dass es
Bundeskanzler Scholz weniger um die
israelische Kriegsführung die Strategie
geben wird sondern tatsächlich konkret
auch um die Frage der Geiseln er wird
Angehörige von deutschen Geiseln morgen
treffen und er wird natürlich Gespräche
führen sowohl in Israel dass zumindest
die Israelis soweit möglich Rück
rüksicht nehmen auf das Schicksal der
Geisel und er wird gleich weiterfliegen
nach Kairo aber die Frage ist was
tatsächlich erreicht werden kann es gab
am Abend eine Meldung dass ein
Militärsprecher der Hamas angekündigt
hat zumindest die ausländischen Geiseln
unter bestimmten Bedingungen
freizulassen aber das kann natürlich
teil und Beginn dieses Spiels mit den
Geiseln sein ob das tatsächlich für bare
zu münsten zu nehmen ist das lässt sich
jetzt noch nicht sagen mm danke schön
Michael nach Deutschland die jüdischen
Gemeinden müssen nicht nur den Schock
über das Geschehen in Israel verkraften
mit all den gräulen und der Angst um
Angehörige und Freunde in Israel hinzu
kommt dass sie sich auch hierzulande in
ihrer Heimat massiv bedroht fühlen mehr
als das eh schon der Fall war dass die
Konflikte des Nahen Ostens ihren
wiedderhall auch in Europa finden ist
zwar kein neues Phänomen die but mit der
auch auf deutschen Straßen der Terror
der Hamas relativiert und gar bejubelt
wird hat Politik und Sicherheitsbehörden
aber doch aufgeschreckt mit Vereins und
versammlungsverboten will man nun
gegensteuern Andreas Huppert berichtet
aus
Berlin palästinensische Fahnen am
potsdammer Platz Berlin gestern am
Nachmittag Demo gegen die israelischen
Angriffe auf den gazraf Palästinenser
und Unterstützer angemeldet war eine
Mahnwache mit Teilnehmern gekommen sind
über 1000 wie viel genau keiner weiß es
die Polizei schreitet ein löst die
genehmigte Demonstration auf nimmt 127
Personen in gewahsam Unverständnis bei
denen die zur Kundgebung aufgerufen
haben es geh um Frieden hier habe
niemand Hass gegen Israel geschürt ich
weiß nicht was mit der deutschen Politik
los ist wir haben heute nicht mal einmal
das Wort Israel erwähnt wir haben nur
gerufen Frieden und frei
stag Frankfurt auch hier eineästiner
Demo hunderte sind gekommen obwohl die
Stadt ein Verbot ausgesprochen
hatte ss wie mit freier Meinungsäußerung
Menschen die sich hinstellen und Terror
verteidigen sagen im Grunde genommen
auch deutlich dass sie die Werte unsere
Werte ablehnen die Werte des
Grundgesetzes ablehnen pauschale
Demonstrationsverbote das halte ich für
ein Problem weil das da natürlich
einfach um Grundrechte geht deswegen ist
eben die Frage was genau was geschieht
dort genau klar ist wer Hass und Hetze
ver h verherlicht und Israel das
Existenzrecht abspricht der verliert
jegliches Demonstrationsrecht der
Verfassungsschutz hat übrigens
Erkenntnisse dass in Deutschland etliche
hamasunterstützer leben die unter
anderem den Terror von hier aus
finanzieren deshalb ist es wichtig dass
sich jetzt an dieser Stelle der Staat
wehrhaft zeigt ich halte die von Kanzler
Scholz angekündigten betätig und
vereinsverbote für
erforderlich der jüdischen Gemeinde in
Frankfurt am Main fordert die
bundesinnenministerin eine deutliche
Distanzierung zur Hamas auch von den
Palästinensern hier im Lande auch auf
Demonstrationen ich erwarte eine
glasklare Abgrenzung vom Terror der
ramas und das muss dieser Tage auch
erfolgen
ansonsten ist es schwierig mit dem
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt wir als
jüdische Gemeinschaft dürfen uns nicht
einschüchtern lassen unser Leben geht
weiter wenn auch
anders wie anders zeigt sich auch am
Abend in Berlin Gedenkgottesdienst für
die von der hamasse entführten jüdischen
Geisel der Krieg in naost stellt Politik
und Gesellschaft hierzulande vor neue
Herausforderungen Philip Peimann Engel
ist uns zugeschaltet der Chefredakteur
der in Berlin herausgegebenen Zeitung
jüdische allgemeine guten Abend Herr
Engel ja guten Abend hallo diese
Ereignisse sind am am letzten Samstag am
am Schabbat vor 10 Tagen über sie
hereingebrochen wie über uns alle und
seitdem ist ihre Redaktion in eine Art
Ausnahmezustand haben sie
gesagt ja völlig richtig wir sind nach
wie vor in einem Ausnahmezustand ähm wir
berichten außerordentlich viel so viel
wie noch nie in der Geschichte der
jüdischen allgemeinen haben auch dieses
Wochenende wieder den Schabbat gebrochen
zum zweiten Mal erst in der Geschichte
der jüdischen allgemein da ist ja immer
das Kriterium mit der Berichterstattung
womöglich
dazu beizutragen Leben zu retten das
haben wir an diesem Wochenende auch
wieder gemacht als wir vermelden mussten
dass die Sicherheit der jüdischen
Gemeinden noch mal hochgefahren wurde
und dann eben auch eine extrem hohe oder
eine erhöhte Gefährdungslage besteht für
jüdische Institutionen ja wir sind
absolut im Ausnahmezustand unsere
Korrespondentin in Tel Aviv hat ihre
beiden Kinder nach Deutschland
Ausfliegen lassen ja das sindterässt
schon starke Spur
Herr Engel sie sind ja erst seit vier
Wochen Chefredakteur der jüdischen
allgemein gab es ein Generationenwechsel
in der Redaktion der auch auch so
gewollt war und haben zu ihrem zum
Antritt ihrer neuen Position gesagt sie
möchten gern jüdisches Leben in
Deutschland sichtbarer machen und nun
sind sie eigentlich ein Situation wo
ganz viele Mitglieder der jüdischen
Community ja sich eigentlich eher aus
aus Angst Moment eher unsichtbar machen
das ist eine richtige
Zustandsbeschreibung
aus guten Grund
herrscht im Moment große Angst in der
jüdischen Gemeinschaft in Deutschland am
vergangenen Freitag hatte die Hamas ja
weltweit zum Tag des Zorns aufgerufen
und dazu aufgerufen Israelis zu ermorden
aber auch Juden weltweit zu ermorden
jüdische Kitas in Deutschland sind leer
geblieben weitesgehend jüdische Schulen
in Deutschland sind weitesgehend
leer geblieben wir erleben dass in sehr
sehr vielen Städten in Deutschland pro
Palästinenser auf die Straße gehen den
Terror der Hamas feiern antisemitische
Slogans rufen ja unsere Aufgabe ist es
jüdisches Leben in Deutschland
abzubilden in dem Fall tun wir das
natürlich auch aber anders als wir uns
das vorgenommen haben es sind keine
guten Tage es sind ganz ganz düstere
Tage in der Geschichte Israels aber auch
in der Geschichte der jüdischen
Gemeinschaft in Deutschland
standen jüdische Synagogen immer schon
auch unter nicht immer schon aber eben
seit langer Zeit unter unter
Polizeischutz sie sind im Ruhrgebiet
aufgewachsen sie sind 40 sie sind ja mit
diesem Gefühl von nicht nicht wirklich
sicher sein auch aufgewachsen würden sie
doch sagen dass es jetzt ein vorher und
ein nachher gibt und dieser 7 oktober
als eine Art zesur empfunden
wird ja der der Tag ist ganz klar eine
zesur also es sind noch nie so viele
Juden an einem Tag seit dem Holocaust
seit der Schoa ermordet worden über 1300
Israelis das ist ganz kleine zesur es
sind ganz ganz düstere Stunden und ja
die jüdische Gemeinschaft ist schockiert
ich wird auch sagen ein Stück weit
traumatisiert wir sind alle entsetzt
fassungslos in tiefer tiefer Trauer aber
auch in grenzenloser Wut also wie konnte
das passieren mm wurden von deutschen
Politikern von von Sicherheitsbehörden
Verfassungsschutz Innenministerin und so
weiter angekündigt man werde
hamasfreundliche Vereine unterbinden man
versucht das Versammlungsverbot
durchzusetzen solche Demonstrationen gar
nicht erst zuzulassen wie wie nehmen sie
das wahr reicht das hilft
das solche Schritte sind erst einmal
richtig aber man muss auch ganz klar
dazu sagen viel viel zu spät ich selber
Berichte seit über 10 Jahren wirklich
über antisemitische Demonstration in
Berlin diese Demonstrationen auch die
Organisatoren die hat es schon immer
gegeben und auch die entsprechende
Berichterstattung darüber und dass jetzt
erst
sozusagen aufgewacht wird auf
politischer Ebene es ist
ja gut das ist jetzt erfreulich das
gehandelt wird aber wie gesagt eben viel
viel zu spät und das reicht natürlich
nicht also es ist wirklich auch eine
sehr bittere Erkenntnis aus den
vergangenen Tagen in vielen Städten wird
von arabischstämmigen Migranten oder von
deutschen mit arabischen mit
muslimischen Hintergrund demonstriert
gegen Juden der Terror der Tod von Juden
wird der Terror gegen Juden der Tod von
Juden wird gefeiert es ist eine bittere
Erkenntnis wir sind teilweise ja
umzingelt teilweise umgeben von Feinden
die den Tod von Juden gut heißen und ja
da ist jetzt auch die Politik an der
Reihe um Ansagen zu machen wie damit
umgehen Herr Engel danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch danke Ihnen Frau
somomker das Interview haben wir vor
einer Stunde geführt zu den Fragen der
inneren Sicherheit gibt es nachher im
heute journal Update noch ein Gespräch
mit dem Innenminister nordrenwestfalens
mit Herbert
re wie gesagt eben dieser Krieg findet
auch Wiederhall an deutschen Schulen
Antisemitismus verschiedener kouleur mit
und ohne Migrationshintergrund gab es da
auch vorher schon aber jetzt wird das
noch mal aufgeheizt da sind Kinder und
Jugendliche die mit Israelhass in der
Familie aufgewachsen sind wo die
dauerkonflikte des Nahen Ostens und ihre
flüchtlingstragödien teils zur eigenen
Identität gehören da sind andere bei
denen Unwissenheit zu einer
falschverstandenen Solidarität führt für
die Parolen wie from the river to the
sea nach gerechtem Freiheitskampf
klingen ohne sich bewusst zu sein was
damit tatsächlich gemeint ist nämlich
dass der Staat Israel von der Landkarte
verschwindet und dann sind da Lehrer und
Lehrerinnen die irgendwie versuchen
sollen was in der Erwachsenen Welt auch
nicht gelingt zu befrieden Eindrücke
dazu von Dominik Müller
Russell es ist schwieriger Stoff der
heute an der Trude Herr Gesamtschule in
kölnmülheim auf dem Plan steht die erste
Unterrichtsstunde seit den Herbstferien
seit dem Überfall der ham
es gilt für Klassenlehrer Felix R in
seiner neen Klasse erstmal einige Dinge
zu ordnen dann muss man sich vorstellen
dass die Palästinenser nicht alle
hamasanhänger sind dass die Hamas nicht
quasi die Palästinenser per se sind wie
reagieren die Schülerinnen und Schüler
gerade an einer brennpunktschule wie
hier in Köln Mülheim mit hohem
Migrantenanteil gibt es gar
antisemitische Stimmen rechtfertigen
Schüler den Terror und was ma die
Nachrichtenbilder mit Kindern die
Verwandte haben die nun von dem Krieg in
Israel im Gaza betroffen sind haben das
kann vielleicht auch an Schule für eine
Dynamik entstehen wenn gerade Schüler
zusammenkommen und wir wissen ja auch
nicht was die für Materialien gesehen
haben wo sind die Bedarfe was müssen wir
machen wollen die Schüler darüber
sprechen wollen sie es thematisieren und
dann sind wir auf jeden Fall da doch wie
gelingt das am besten dieses
thematisieren an einer Realschule in
Krefeld heute Lehrerfortbildung es geht
auch um Antisemitismus und den
nostkonflikt und wie man da Grenzen
zieht und
einordnet ich glaube das Wichtige ist
aber dass man aus einer Haltung heraus
muss die erstmal erklärt und bewertet
sondern jetzt gerade ist auch die Zeit
des Zuhörens die Zeit Emotionen auch
Raum zu geben diese Emotionen solange
sie nicht hasserfüllt sind ernst nehmen
rett auch die
Antidiskriminierungsstelle der jüdischen
Gemeinde Düsseldorf um so miteinander
ins Gespräch Z antisemitisch da ist
jemand den betrifft etwas sehr stark und
dann muss ich darauf pädagogisch
reagieren so und wir wissen ja dass es
vielfach bei Jugendlichen eben noch
keine gefestigten Weltbilder gibt und
genau dann kann man da ansetzen auch
damit Hassbotschaften nicht verfangen
einige Schüler in Köln Mülheim Berichten
schon von einem Lagerdenken das entsteht
wir gegen die da ist halt so bisschen
böses Blut mit drin und dementsprechend
ist dann auch die Situation also
ist halt so ein Gegensatz finde ich das
was z.B in Berlin vorgefallen ist mit
dem Schüler und dem Lehrer es war ja
schon so ein bisschen extremer und ja
also ich hoffe einfach dass die weiteren
Demonstrationen wenn sie kommen
friedlich bleiben sie hören heute viel
zu an der Trud der Herr Gesamtschule und
erklären damit ein größeres Bild
entsteht bei ihren Schülerinnen und
Schülern am Ende ist es glaube ich aber
wichtig dass wir klarstellen dass es
hier nicht um einfache Bewertung
schwarz-weiß geht oder auch nicht darum
geht Partei zu ergreifen sondern dass
wir versuchen diesen humanistischen
Gedanken zu stärken und zu fördern und
den Gedanken an Frieden bzw auch das
Mitgefühl für die Betroffenen dort dann
wirklich zu zu stärken der erste
Schultag verlief heute ruhig in
kölnmülheim sie sind vorbereitet auch in
den nächsten Wochen viel auf ihre
Schülerinnen und Schüler
einzugehen und jetzt geht es bei dir
erstmal weiter zunächst mit dem was
heute Abend aus Brüssel gemeldet wird ja
dort sind offenbar zwei Menschen
erschossen worden Belgiens
Premierminister zufolge waren die Opfer
Schweden belgische Medienberichten von
einem Terrorverdacht die Ermittlungen
zum Vorfall dauern an teilte eine
Sprecherin der Polizei mit die gegen dem
Stadtzentrum wurde abgeriegelt der
belgischen Nachrichtenagentur Belger
zufolge gab es zunächst keine Festnahme
ein bewaffneter Mann soll in einem
Hauseingang auf die Menschen geschossen
haben weitere Einzelheiten gibt es
bislang nicht auch die Hintergründe der
Tat sind noch
unklar die Bundespolizei erhält im
Einsatz gegen Schleuser und irreguläre
Migration jetzt mehr Möglichkeiten an
den Grenzen zu Polen Tschechien und der
Schweiz nun kann laut Innenministerin
fäser das gesamte Bündel an stationären
und mobilen grenzpolizeilichen Maßnahmen
eingesetzt werden über diese
vorübergehenden Grenzkontrollen sei
heute die EU-Kommission in Kenntnis
gesetzt worden bislang gab es bereits
etwa Schwerpunktkontrollen und
schleierverandung im Zuge der weiteren
Annäherung der Staaten des Westbalkans
an die EU gab es heute ein weiteres
Gipfeltreffen an dem auch Bundeskanzler
Scholz teilnahm die Konferenz in der
albanischen Hauptstadt Tirana wurde
überschattet vom jüngsten Konflikt
zwischen Serbien und Kosovo Scholz und
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Lin
forderten beide Seiten auf ihre
Spannungen Beiz
zulegen mit einer Schweigeminute haben
Schulen in ganz Frankreich des Lehrers
Dominik Bernard gedacht der am Freitag
von einem islamistisch radikalisierten
Mann erstochen wurde im
nordfranzösischen Aras wo sich die Tat
ereignet hatte musste das Gymnasium
aufgrund einer Bombendrohung
vorübergehend geräumt werden ein
Fehlalarm wie die Einsatzkräfte
feststellten es war zugleich der dritte
jahrestag des Anschlags auf den Lehrer
Samuel PTI der ebenfalls von einem
dsihadisten getötet worden
war Ecuador hat einen neuen Präsidenten
Daniel noboa Spross einer Milliarden
schweren bananendynastie ist mit 35
Jahren der jüngste demokratisch gewählte
Präsident in der Geschichte des
südamerikanischen Landes der Mitte
Rechtspolitiker war mit dem Versprechen
angetreten neue Arbeitsplätze für junge
Menschen zu schaffen und die schwierige
Sicherheitslage in den Griff zu bekommen
eador kämpft g gegen den wachsenden
Einfluss von Drogenkartellen und damit
verbunden hoher Kriminalität und
Gewalt ganz Europa hat auf die Wahlen
gestern in Polen geblickt und das
Ergebnis ist umso bemerkenswerter wenn
man sich vor Augen hält wie die
regierende peace diesen Staat und auch
die Medienlandschaft bereits nach Ihren
Vorstellungen umgestaltet hat wie
schwierig es also für die Opposition war
überhaupt einen öffentlichkeitswirksamen
Wahlkampf zu führen und doch besteht nun
reelle Chance dass Polen eines der
größten und längst auch sehr
einflussreichen EU-Mitglieder wieder von
einer Koalition regiert wird die dieses
Europa prinzipiell bejaht und die
aushölung rechtsstaatlicher Prinzipien
rückgängig macht der Weg dahin könnte
allerdings noch lang und holprig werden
auch wenn die regierende peace ihre
parlamentarische Mehrheit verloren hat
aus Warschau Andreas
kün in diesem Auto sitzt Jaros und hat
ein Problem das Problem ist ein Satz den
er selbst vor einer Woche über die
Bauernpartei gesagt hat und der ging
so es gibt keine bitte entschuldigen Sie
die Ausdrucksweise keine größere
Dummheit als zu sagen dass die
irgendwelche Kompetenzen haben das sind
Banausen und
Faulpelze len Kinskis Problem als er
heute in die paceparteizentrale fährt er
braucht einen Koalitionspartner aber die
Faulpelze von der Bauernpartei haben
nicht völlig überraschend abgesagt dass
es über alle anderen Parteien auch
problemsetze katinskis gibt darüber kann
sich sein Herausforderer sicher
sein wir haben es geschafft wirklich die
Bilder die Donald Tusks Bürgerplattform
gestern ihrer Regierungsbildung
entgegentanzt sind heute schon
historisch in Polen ist eine Bastion des
Rechtspopulismus
gefallen
ich bin Politiker und ich bin Sportler
und ich war noch nie in meinem Leben so
glücklich über einen zweiten Platz Polen
hat gewonnen die Demokratie hat gewonnen
wir haben die Pace von der Macht
entfernt rechnerisch können die neue
Linke der konservative dritte Weg und
Tusks bürgerkoalition eine Koalition
bilden die rechtsextreme konfederatiia
und die peace kommen auch zusammen nicht
auf eine me
ich bin sehr proeuropäisch und ich hoffe
dass die polnische Regierung aufhört
sich mit den anderen Mitgliedstaaten zu
streiten ich habe ein bisschen Angst man
hat gesehen was die Opposition uns alles
wegnehmen will das hat nichts Gutes zu
bedeuten Europa schaut ein bisschen
sprachlos auf die Bilder die den
polnischen demokratierekord zeigen die
Schlange der Auslandspolen die vor dem
Londoner Wahllokal warten sich einmal um
den Block in bresslau warten die Leute
bis 3 Uhr morgens eine
gesamtwahlbeteiligung von fast
3% so etwas gab es in Polen noch
nie ich gratuliere denen die gewonnen
haben von ganzem Herzen wen meint er
katinskis Freund der Präsident das fragt
sich an diesem Abend ganz Polen und wen
wird er zuerst mit der Regierungsbildung
beauftragen den Mann mit der Mehrheit
oder den Mann mit dem
Problem und jetzt noch mal eins mit
anderen Meldungen die Bundesregierung
will die Familienförderung beim Hausbau
ausweiten die Konditionen für
zinsverbilligte Kredite für ein eigenes
klimafreundliches Haus werden nach
Angaben des Bauministeriums verbessert
werie Haller wie sehen die neuen
Konditionen aus also die Bundesregierung
hofft dass die Konditionen nun so
aussehen dass Familien sie auch wirklich
in Anspruch nehmen wollen das Programm
ist ja schon im Juni gestartet und
erstmal gefloppt kritisiert wurden vor
allem die Einkommensgrenzen Bauherren
durften nicht zu viel verdienen ja und
diese die wurden jetzt eben angehoben
die Einkommensgrenze für Familien mit
einem Kind liegt nun beispielsweise bei
90.000 € verbessert wurden auch die
Konditionen für zinsgünstige Kredite die
Obergrenze liegt jetzt bei 270.000 €
Veraussetzung für die Förderung es muss
ein klimafreundlicher Neubau sein den
man auch selbst bewohnen will die
Konditionen gelten direkt seit heute und
wie steht's insgesamt im Moment um den
Wohnungsbau in Deutschland ja die
Stimmung ist so schlecht wie seit gut 30
Jahren nicht mehr das ifo Institut nennt
die Lage sogar dramatisch in der
monatlichen Branchenumfrage gaben mehr
als 20% der Firmen an von Stornierungen
betroffen zu sein so viele wie noch nie
auch die Auftragslage ist mies Grund
sind nach wie vor die stark gestiegenen
Baukosten und die höheren Zinsen das
dürfte Folgen haben für die Zukunft
schließlich fehlen schon jetzt viele
Wohnungen Valerie Haller vielen
Dank am Abend ist im Frankfurter Römer
der Deutsche Buchpreis verliehen worden
als bestes deutschsprachiges Werk wurde
der Roman echtzeitalter des
österreichischen Autoren Tonio
Schachinger ausgezeichnet die Geschichte
handelt von einem Jugendlichen der
versucht durch Gaming aus einer eher
konservativen Welt auszubrechen mit
feinsinniger Ironie spiegle der Autor
die politische und sozialen Verhältnisse
der Gegenwart so die Jury zur Begründung
die Preisverleihung findet traditionell
am Tag vor begineginn der Frankfurter
Buchmesse
statt das war es im heute journal aus
Brüssel heinz hat es ja eben schon
gemeldet wo es eben zwei tödliche
Schüsse gab gibt's inzwischen die
Meldung dass der belgische
Premierminister von Terror spricht dass
das Fußballspiel am Abend zwischen
Belgien und Schweden unterbrochen wurde
und die Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen
aber aufgefordert nicht das Stadion zu
verlassen mehr wissen wir im Moment noch
nicht aber unsere Kollegen vom heute
journal Update werden Sie auf jeden Fall
weiter informieren und auf dem Laufenden
halten das macht gunduler Gause um
23:r55 und das war's von uns für den
Moment gleich gibt's das Wetter und
danach das montagskino so ist es auch
Wieders seehen bis morgen bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend es ist viel los am Himmel
über Europa da gibt's ein Hoch namens
Verena das ostwärts zieht das Tief Uwe
bringt Schnee nach Skandinavien und das
Tief Victor über dem Atlantik bringt zur
Wochenmitte noch mal deutlich mildere
Luft von Südwesten heran heute Nacht
aber wird's erstmal kalt da sinken die
Werte auf + 3 bis -3 gr es droht also
verbreitet Bodenfrost da sollten Sie
Ihre empfindlichen Pflanzen schützen
milder bleibt die Nacht an den Küsten
von Ost und Nordsee und auch am
niederrein bei 10 bis 4° dazu ist es mal
mehr mal weniger stark bewölken es
bildet sich Nebel und wenn der sich
morgen aufgelöst hat dann wird das ein
meist recht freundlicher Tag mit Sonne
und wolkenwechsel manchmal ist auch
stärker bewirkt wie im Süden oder auch
im Osten scheswiichholstein gibt's noch
einige Regenschauer die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 10 und 16° und dann wird es bis
zum Donnerstag deutlich milder wir
erwarten im Südwesten tatsächlich noch
mal bis zu 21° im Nordosten dagegen sind
es nur so 9 bis 11° das ist allerdings
nur vorübergehend diese Wärme da im
Südwesten denn schon zum Samstag liegen
die Höchsttemperaturen hier im Nordosten
nur noch bei 3 bis 7° und das macht sich
natürlich auch beim Wetter bemerkbar am
Mittwoch ändert sich wenig am Donnerstag
regnet es hier im Nordosten und die
Temperaturgegensätze haben sich
verschärft am Freitag droht dann Sturm
an der Nordseeküste und am Samstag
könnte es dann für schne Fälle nicht nur
in den Mittelgebirgen sondern auch im
Flachland reichen guten Abend